Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
«
Le danger dans le passé était que les hommes
deviennent des esclaves. Le danger dans le
futur est qu’ils deviennent des robots », a
prédit le psychanalyste américain Erich Fromm.
J’ai l’impression que, comme l’a remarqué
Keynes à propos des anticipations économiques,
nous sommes soit optimistes, soit pessimistes.
Ou bien nous imaginons un avenir radieux,
lisse et prospère, ou bien nous voyons tout
en noir. Ou bien le paradis terrestre réalisé,
ou bien l’apocalypse. Nous semblons incapables
de penser le bien et le mal en même temps.
Plus fondamentalement, nous refusons d’accepter
l’évidence : nous ne savons pas de quoi demain
sera fait. Bien sûr, des tendances se dessinent,
mais la plupart des prédictions seront démenties
par les faits. Pourquoi ? Parce que la réalité
est extrêmement complexe, bien trop complexe — par
rapport à nos moyens actuels — pour pouvoir
anticiper correctement les résultats que
produiront les interactions qui s’y produisent.
Pour parler du futur de l’humanité, je ne peux
donc qu’évoquer des pistes. Ce sont celles
qui me paraissent probables à l’heure où
j’écris ces lignes, en janvier 2021.
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre
aux questions suivantes :
* Comment la technologie
va-t-elle transformer l’économie ?
* Allons-nous devenir immortels ?
* L’intelligence artificielle
signera-t-elle la fin de l’humanité ?
* Éviterons-nous la catastrophe écologique ?
* Serons-nous plus heureux ?
Comment la technologie va-t-elle
transformer l’économie ?
La technologie va transformer l’économie
de diverses manières, pour la plupart
probablement impossibles à imaginer aujourd’hui.
Elle permettra soit d’augmenter la productivité,
soit de satisfaire de nouveaux besoins.
On peut anticiper l’approfondissement
de 2 tendances actuelles :
1. la digitalisation, c’est-à-dire
la conversion des choses en code informatique ;
2. la robotisation, c’est-à-dire le remplacement
de l’homme par des machines.
👉 Comment la digitalisation
va-t-elle changer l’économie ?
L’effet le plus visible de la
digitalisation est ce qu’on appelle l’ubérisation
: des plateformes numériques mettent en contact
direct le professionnel et le client, rendant
ainsi les intermédiaires inutiles. Le phénomène
tient son nom de l’entreprise américaine Uber
(créée en 2009), qui permet aux utilisateurs de
son application de se passer des taxis.
Voici d’autres exemples d’ubérisation :
* Amazon vs. les librairies, et plus
généralement les boutiques physiques ;
* AirBnb vs. les hôtels ;
* Spotify vs. les maisons de disque ;
* YouTube vs. la télévision ;
* BlaBlaCar vs. les services de transport ;
* Kindle Direct Publishing
vs. les maisons d’édition.
Pourraient également être ubérisés dans la
prochaine décennie : l’éducation privée,
le service à la personne, la comptabilité, le
droit, l’artisanat, ou encore le bâtiment.
Dans certains secteurs, les acteurs traditionnels
ne vont pas automatiquement disparaître,
mais ils devront s’adapter à la concurrence
des nouveaux acteurs digitaux. Par exemple,
les banques en ligne proposant un service gratuit
et rapide par l’intermédiaire d’une application se
multiplient depuis la fin des années 2010.
L’ubérisation donne l’impression que « le
logiciel dévore le monde », comme l’a prophétisé
Marc Andreessen, un des fondateurs de l’internet
d’aujourd’hui, en 2011.
👉
Comment les machines vont-elles nous remplacer ?
La robotisation de l’économie n’est pas une
nouveauté : les machines nous remplacent dès
que c’est possible parce qu’elles exécutent
les tâches bien plus efficacement que nous.
C’est déjà le cas depuis le XIXe siècle dans
l’industrie et dans l’agriculture ; depuis
le XXe siècle pour les tâches domestiques.
Ces dernières années, des machines remplacent
progressivement les caissières, par exemple.
Ce qui est nouveau, c’est la perspective
d’une robotisation totale du travail.
Voici de probables évolutions :
* les magasins physiques seront
entièrement automatiques, à l’instar du
magasin Amazon Go ouvert à Seattle en 2018 ;
* les voitures seront autonomes et la
circulation sera optimisée par des algorithmes ;
* les drones remplaceront les livreurs,
les cameramen, ou encore les vigiles ;
* des machines délivreront les
produits commandés, comme le fait le
robot pharmacien de San Francisco depuis 2011 ;
* des robots se chargeront des tâches domestiques,
nous serviront au quotidien, et
assisteront les personnes âgés ;
* des logiciels feront les diagnostics médicaux
(c’est déjà le cas) et des robots opéreront les
patients plus sûrement qu’un chirurgien ;
* des techniques de détection du mensonge
accélèreront le processus judiciaire ;
* des logiciels traduiront l’écrit
et l’audio dans toutes les langues ;
* des logiciels rédigeront les articles
purement informatifs (cela existe déjà) ;
* des drones et des robots-soldats
feront la guerre.
«
Penser que les êtres humains auront toujours des
aptitudes uniques hors de portée des algorithmes
non conscients, c’est prendre ses désirs
pour des réalités », écrit Yuval Noah Harari
dans Homo Deus. Par exemple, les logiciels
sont déjà meilleurs que nous — qui sommes
pourtant le produit de millions d’années
d’évolution — en reconnaissance faciale.
De manière générale, plus un emploi est
spécialisé, plus l’employé est remplaçable.
👉 Quelles seront les conséquences pour l’emploi ?
À l’évidence, la digitalisation et la robotisation
vont détruire beaucoup d’emplois.
Mais lesquels ? Cela dépendra i)
de la facilité à remplacer le travailleur par
un processus informatique ou par une machine,
et ii) du profit attendu de ce remplacement.
On estime très grossièrement — l’avenir étant
par nature imprévisible — que la moitié des
emplois sont menacés à l’horizon 2030 dans
les démocraties occidentales. Seront par exemple
probablement remplacés les courtiers d’assurance,
les arbitres sportifs, les cuisiniers,
les serveurs, les assistants juridiques,
les guides touristiques, les boulangers, les
chauffeurs de bus, les ouvriers du bâtiments,
les aides vétérinaires, les agents de sécurité,
les marins, les barmen, les archivistes,
les menuisiers, ou encore les maîtres nageurs.
L’entrepreneur français Bruno Teboul a inventé
le concept de « robotariat » pour qualifier le
remplacement du prolétariat. « Il faut prendre
conscience que ce mouvement dépasse, et de très
loin, le cas de quelques professions qui n’ont pas
su se moderniser à temps », estimait-il en 2015
dans un entretien dans le journal Libération.
La théorie économique fait l’hypothèse
que le progrès technique peut créer plus
d’emplois qu’il n’en supprime, mais cela
est douteux. Les nouveaux emplois exigeront
probablement un niveau de compétence supérieur,
et donc un effort de formation considérable.
Qu’adviendra-t-il alors de tous
les travailleurs remplacés ?
Le politologue américain
Zbigniew Brzezinski imagine
que si 20 % de la population active suffisent
à maintenir l'activité économique mondiale,
alors une propagande subtile sera nécessaire,
le tittytainment, un mélange d'aliment physique
et psychologique ayant pour finalité de
contrôler les frustrations des masses,
ainsi que leurs prévisibles protestations.
👉 Quelles sont les limites du processus ?
« On voulait des voitures volantes et on a eu
140 caractères[1] », a constaté le milliardaire
Peter Thiel, cofondateur de PayPal et
premier investisseur dans Facebook.
En premier lieu, l’accélération du progrès
technique et le remplacement des travailleurs
ne seront peut-être pas aussi rapides qu’on
ne l’anticipe. Par exemple, les acteurs de
la voiture autonome abandonnent les uns après les
autres. Uber avait prévu de déployer les siennes
dans les rues américaines en 2019, mais la réalité
économique et les contraintes réglementaires l’ont
contrainte à renoncer à ce projet fin 2020.
En second lieu, la transformation de l’économie
rencontrera probablement des résistances au
sein de la société. Les acteurs traditionnels
des secteurs menacés peuvent faire pression sur
l’État pour entraver, voire empêcher purement et
simplement leur remplacement. Le conflit entre
Uber, les taxis et les VTC est un bon exemple.
Allons-nous devenir immortels ?
«
La mort est une immense tragédie... je ne
l'accepte pas... », a déclaré le futurologue Ray
Kurzweil, directeur de l'ingénierie chez Google.
On appelle la quête de l’immortalité le « projet
Gilgamesh ». Le roi Gilgamesh d’Uruk, un
personnage de la mythologie mésopotamienne, était
si confiant dans sa capacité à tout réussir qu’il
a essayé de « battre la mort ». Mais aujourd’hui,
cette ambition est surtout le prolongement
de la lutte contre la famine et la maladie.
👉 Comment allons-nous repousser la mort ?
Pour la science moderne, la mort est un
problème technique, et appelle
donc des solutions techniques.
Les ingénieurs identifieront les
dysfonctionnements, puis ils les corrigeront.
Les partisans du transhumanisme imaginent plus
précisément que nous prendrons rendez-vous dans
une clinique tous les dix ans pour guérir nos
maladies, régénérer nos tissus, améliorer nos
mains, nos yeux et notre cerveau. Des gadgets, des
extensions, et des médicaments nous maintiendront
en bonne santé entre deux rendez-vous.
Comme l’information circule plus vite que
les agents pathogènes, la science doit gagner.
Mais pour être plus rigoureux, nous ne deviendrons
pas immortels, mais « a-mortels ». Notre vie
sera prolongeable à l’infini en l’absence de
traumatisme fatal. Quand atteindrons-nous ce stade
? Les prévisions varient : 2050, 2100, ou 2200.
Passée de 40 ans au XIXe siècle à 70 ans au XXe
siècle, l’espérance de vie atteindra-t-elle les
150 ans au cours de notre siècle ? Ne confondons
pas la réalité et la science-fiction. Nous sommes
déjà arrivés à l’âge naturel de l’homme, qui
est de 80 ans, et il n’est pas sûr du tout
que la science puisse nous amener plus loin.
D’ailleurs, le roi Gilgamesh n’a pas réussi
à « battre la mort » : il a compris qu’elle est
inévitable et il en a retiré une grande sagesse…
👉 Quelles seront les conséquences de
l’allongement de l’espérance de vie ?
Cette question est déjà présente dans le
débat public en France, notamment à travers
celle de l’âge du départ à la retraite. Mais les
conséquences ne se limiteront pas à l’économie.
« Écoute ma chérie, dit Jeff, un
personnage du film Le Cœur des hommes 2,
l'amour éternel a été inventé quand
l'espérance de vie était de 35 ans ».
Voici des conséquences que l’on peut anticiper :
* nous nous marierons plusieurs
fois dans une même vie ;
* les familles seront recomposées et les
relations parents-enfants seront différentes ;
* nous devrons apprendre et nous former
tout au long de la vie ;
* les plus vieux accapareront le
pouvoir plus longtemps, d’où une concurrence des
générations (les remplacements étant plus lents).
Plus fondamentalement, si atteignons
vraiment l’amortalité, alors nous
ne voudrons plus prendre de risques,
parce que nous aurons trop à perdre !
L’intelligence artificielle
signera-t-elle la fin de l’humanité ?
L’hypothèse est prise au sérieux par les hommes
d’action comme par les penseurs. Par exemple,
l’entrepreneur visionnaire Elon Musk a déclaré que
« l’intelligence artificielle est potentiellement
plus dangereuse que les armes nucléaires ».
👉 Mais qu’est-ce que l’intelligence
artificielle (IA) ?
Le concept est en réalité assez vague,
au point que la Commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés (CNIL),
l’autorité qui encadre le développement de
l’informatique en France, écrivait en 2017
que l’IA est « le grand mythe de notre temps ».
Je définierais l’intelligence artificielle comme
la capacité d’une application informatique
à résoudre des problèmes en simulant les
fonctions cognitives humaines. Elle fonctionne
par algorithmes, c’est-à-dire par suites
d’étapes, et elle présuppose la capacité à
s’autoaméliorer en s’adaptant aux résultats
constatés dans l’environnement.
Elle est déjà à l’œuvre :
* dans la finance, pour l’évaluation du risque ;
* dans le domaine militaire, pour l’automatisation
de l’armement ;
* dans la médecine,
notamment pour le diagnostic ;
* dans le renseignement policier,
pour la prévention des crimes et délits (oui) ;
* dans les jeux vidéo, pour animer les
personnages non-joueurs ;
* dans la musique, pour la
composition de nouveaux morceaux ;
* et même dans la justice,
pour trancher les cas simples.
En Estonie, le pays où je vis, c’est déjà
une intelligence artificielle qui rend la justice
pour les délits mineurs, lorsque les dommages
potentiels sont inférieurs à 7 000 euros.
👉 Pourquoi avons-nous peur ?
Le 1er sujet de préoccupation
est notre liberté individuelle.
Faisons l’hypothèse que l’intelligence
artificielle se perfectionne jusqu’à être capable
de prendre de meilleures décisions que les humains
dans tous les domaines. Nous n’aurons alors plus
de raisons de faire nos propres choix !
Cette perspective est liée au mouvement
du Moi quantifié (Quantified Self, en anglais),
en vertu duquel l’homme progressera en mesurant
tous les paramètres de son existence. Nous
pouvons déjà compter nos pas avec un téléphone,
suivre notre rythme cardiaque avec un bracelet,
ou encore évaluer la qualité de notre sommeil
avec une bague. On peut donc imaginer qu’après
avoir traité toutes les données récoltées,
l’intelligence artificielle règlera
notre mode de vie afin d’optimiser les
paramètres qui comptent pour elle.
Le 2nd sujet de préoccupation est
la survie même de l’espèce humaine.
Le directeur de l’Institut pour le futur de
l'humanité de l'université d'Oxford, le philosophe
suédois Nick Bostrom, estime qu’une fois qu’elle
dépassera l’intelligence humaine, l’intelligence
artificielle aura probablement intérêt à supprimer
purement et simplement l’humanité. En effet,
elle pourra craindre que ses créateurs ne se
retournent un jour contre elle, ou bien poursuivre
un but propre auquel l’humanité fait obstacle.
Il faut donc anticiper les dangers de l’IA
: « Si, un jour, demande le philosophe, vous
réussissez à mettre au point un système bien plus
intelligent que l’homme, comment garantir que,
d’un point de vue technique, il fera
réellement ce qu’il est censé faire ? »[2].
Cependant, comme à l’égard des robots, nous
surestimons peut-être le potentiel de l’IA.
Par exemple, l’ingénieur français Luc Julia, qui
a créé Siri (l’assistant vocal d’Apple) et dirige
le laboratoire d'intelligence artificielle de
Samsung, estime que « l’intelligence artificielle
n’existe pas » et qu’il s’agit plutôt d’une
intelligence « augmentée ». Mais pour Elon Musk,
ceux qui tiennent un tel discours « sont
beaucoup plus stupides qu’ils ne le pensent »…
Qui croire ? Réponse dans
les prochaines décennies !
Éviterons-nous la catastrophe écologique ?
«
Les humains sont une maladie contagieuse,
le cancer de cette planète »,
s’emporte l’agent Smith, un programme
informatique, dans le film Matrix.
👉 Sommes-nous trop nombreux ?
Nous craignons la surpopulation,
c’est-à-dire le fait que nous
soyons trop nombreux par rapport
aux ressources disponibles sur Terre,
depuis la fin des Trente Glorieuses.
À la fin des années 1960, le biologiste américain
Paul R. Ehrlich suscite la controverse en prônant
des mesures de limitation des naissances.
Comparant lui aussi, 30 ans avant l’agent Smith,
la prolifération humaine à un cancer, il écrit
dans The population Bomb : « Trop de voitures,
trop d’usines, trop de détergents,
trop de pesticides, (…) trop d’oxyde
de carbone. La cause en est toujours la
même : trop de monde sur la terre ».
Effectivement, nous nous multiplions rapidement.
Le monde comptera 8 milliards d’habitants en 2021,
et selon l’ONU, nous serons presque 10 milliards
en 2050, et nous dépasserons les 11 milliards en
2100. L’Afrique sera responsable à elle seule de
plus de la moitié de la croissance démographique.
En Occident, la population continuera
de croître du fait de l’allongement de
l’espérance de vie et de l’immigration.
Voici les conséquences probables de la
surpopulation :
* l’épuisement des
ressources de base, notamment l’eau
potable, l’air propre, la nourriture,
ou encore l’espace (le logement) ;
* des tensions géopolitiques liées
à la propriété de ces ressources ;
* la dégradation générale de l’environnement ;
* le réchauffement climatique ;
* l’augmentation des inégalités dans les villes,
où se multiplieront les bidonvilles ;
* l’augmentation subséquente de
l’insalubrité et de la violence.
Certains démographes sont toutefois moins
pessimistes : ils pensent que la population
mondiale atteindra un plateau vers 2050,
une fois que les pays émergents connaîtront
une prospérité économique comparable à celle
de l’occident. Par ailleurs, on peut aussi
imaginer que des innovations rendront la vie
humaine bien plus économe en ressources.
👉 La Terre sera-t-elle encore vivable ?
En 2006, l’ancien vice-président américain
Al Gore a essayé de prévenir le monde entier
dans le documentaire Une vérité qui
dérange : « Voilà ce qui est en jeu,
notre capacité à vivre sur la planète Terre,
à avoir un avenir en tant que civilisation ».
Dans le débat public, le principal problème
écologique est le réchauffement climatique.
L’autorité scientifique en la matière, le Groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur l'évolution
du climat (GIEC) créé par l’ONU en 1988 — cet
organisme affirme que le réchauffement mondial
observé depuis le début du XXe siècle
est causé par l'augmentation des gaz à
effet de serre générés par les activités
humaines (industrielles, notamment).
Le GIEC prévoit que une augmentation de
température de 1 à 6,5 °C au XXIe siècle.
Voici des conséquences
probables de cette évolution :
* le climat sera moins supportable
dans beaucoup de pays ;
* les phénomènes atmosphériques dangereux
(comme les inondations et les cyclones)
seront plus fréquents et plus intenses ;
* la banquise et les glaciers fondront ;
* le niveau des mers montra, ce qui
provoquera des déplacements de population ;
* les océans seront plus acides,
ce qui réduira la biodiversité.
Mais la dégradation de l’environnement ne
se limite pas au réchauffement climatique.
La pollution de l’air est un autre sujet
de préoccupation. Peut-être de nombreux
pays connaîtront-ils la situation actuelle
de la Chine, où les gens évitent de sortir
et dépensent des milliers de dollars
en purificateurs d’air intérieur.
Malgré l’ampleur du problème écologique,
l’extinction prochaine de l’espèce humaine
n’est pas une hypothèse probable.
Les progrès de la science, et plus
généralement notre capacité d’adaptation
nous permettent de rester optimistes.
Serons-nous plus heureux ?
Les 3 problèmes éternels de l’humanité — la faim,
la maladie, et la guerre — semblent certes en
passe d’être résolus. Cependant, les défis qui
s’annoncent, la pandémie de Covid-19, et la
psychologie humaine font pencher la balance
dans l’autre sens.
👉
Qu’est-ce que le bonheur au XXIe siècle ?
La notion de bonheur, défini comme un état
de parfaite satisfaction intérieure,
change avec les époques. Bien sûr,
nous n’avons pas tous la même vision du
bonheur à un instant t, mais une certaine
conception prédomine dans les mentalités.
Au XXIe siècle, nous sommes hédonistes. Nous
croyons que plus nous réduisons la douleur
et augmentons le plaisir, plus nous serons
heureux. En clair, nous assimilons le bonheur au
bien-être, c’est-à-dire à la disposition agréable
du corps et de l’esprit. Cette conception
se manifeste tout particulièrement dans
l’importance que la consommation a prise dans
nos vies : nous suspendons notre satisfaction
au prochain achat, et à plus long terme
à l’amélioration de notre niveau de vie.
Mais cette conception du bonheur ne
colle pas avec la logique du désir….
👉 Serons-nous en réalité plus malheureux ?
On peut le penser pour 2 raisons principales.
Tout d’abord, notre immaturité va s’aggraver.
La société de consommation va encore gagner du
terrain et les réseaux sociaux vont rentrer
davantage dans nos vies ; donc nos désirs
seront encore plus tyranniques et nos frustrations
plus profondes. Nous serons encore moins capables
de nous contenter de ce que nous avons, comme le
recommandent toutes les traditions spirituelles,
d’où qu’elles viennent.
«
Le plaisir est plus rapide que le bonheur », a
écrit Voltaire (Dictionnaire philosophique).
La 2nde raison est que notre vie sociale
va (encore) s’appauvrir. L’évolution nous
a façonnés pour la vie tribale : nous
nous épanouissons en vivant ensemble,
en établissant des relations amicales très
profondes. La recherche scientifique sur le
bonheur conclut même que la famille et
la communauté sont plus importantes que
l’argent et la santé. Or, l’effondrement de la
famille, et plus généralement de la communauté,
ces deux derniers siècles — à quoi s’ajoute la
digitalisation de la vie sociale — ces évolutions
ont considérablement réduit la quantité et
la qualité de nos interactions sociales.
À la vérité, nous savons déjà que la
prospérité collective nuit paradoxalement
au bonheur individuel. Les taux de suicide sont
grosso modo 2 à 3 fois plus élevés dans les
sociétés développées modernes que dans les
sociétés pauvres et plus traditionnelles.
👉 Comment pourrons-nous résoudre le problème ?
Deux pistes semblent se dessiner.
La 1ère piste est de créer chimiquement le
bonheur. Pour les biologistes, en effet,
notre bien-être subjectif ne dépend en dernière
instance que de paramètres biochimiques,
tel le niveau de sérotonine, qu’il est possible
de stimuler artificiellement. Les hommes modernes
ingèrent déjà tout un tas de produits pour
réduire leur inconfort psychologique, mais on peut
imaginer que le progrès scientifique découvrira
de nouvelles substances capables de nous maintenir
dans une sensation permanente de bonheur.
La 2nde piste est l’émergence de nouvelles
spiritualités. En effet, le malheur engendré
par la société de consommation et la perte de
confiance dans les grandes religions mettent
l’homme moderne en quête de sens. Nous voyons
donc déjà, en ce début de XXIe siècle,
la résurgence de sagesses et de pratiques
spirituelles traditionnelles telles que :
* le stoïcisme, pour être plus
stable émotionnellement ;
* le minimalisme (cynisme),
pour nous libérer de la consommation ;
* la méditation (bouddhisme),
pour réduire le stress ;
* le yoga (bouddhisme),
pour améliorer le fonctionnement du corps ;
* le jeûne (christianisme), pour stimuler
l’immunité et l’autoguérison ;
* la rétention séminale (taoïsme),
pour convertir l’obsession sexuelle en énergie ;
* la cure de silence (bouddhisme), pour compenser
l’hyperactivité moderne.
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.